noncardiac percutaneous transluminal
angioplasty a surgeon will perform a
cardiac percutaneous transluminal
angioplasty or NC PTA to restore blood
flow in an artery blocked by
atherosclerosis
fatty deposits called atherosclerosis
can build up inside your arteries
narrowing the passageway and interfering
with blood flow this arterial blockage
is called stenosis insufficient blood
flow to a tissue generally causes pain
a noncardiac percutaneous transluminal
angioplasty is only done when your
condition has not responded to less
invasive treatment options such as
lifestyle changes and medications to
begin the procedure you'll be placed on
a table equipped with a fluoroscope a
fluoroscope is capable of taking x-ray
images of many parts of the body from
multiple angles your doctor will numb
your skin around where the catheter is
to be inserted
since the arteries of the leg are most
easily accessed the femoral artery in
the groin serves as the insertion site
in most cases your doctor will initially
gained access to the artery by inserting
a hollow needle through which the
balloon tip catheter is passed watching
on the fluoroscopy screen your doctor
will gently advance the catheter until
it is positioned in the artery being
treated and eject a special dye this dye
allows the fluoroscope to take x-ray
images called angiograms which lets your
doctor identify the exact location of
the blockages next your doctor will move
the catheter until the deflated balloon
at its tip is positioned at the site of
the stenosis then by rapidly inflating
and deflating the balloon your doctor
will gently push the plaque and vessel
wall out partially re-establishing blood
flow this procedure may be repeated for
any additional blockages in some cases
your doctor may place a stent which is a
wire mesh that remains in the artery to
hold it open to perform this procedure
your doctor will place a collapsed stent
over the deflated balloon on the tip of
the catheter when the balloon is
inflated the stent expands and locks
into place
at the end of the procedure your doctor
will remove the catheter through the
original insertion site
after your procedure a pressure bandage
will be applied to the catheter
insertion site and you will be asked to
lie still to prevent bleeding you will
be carefully monitored in the recovery
area to be sure blood flow through the
affected artery is maintained most
patients are discharged the same day as
their procedure but some remain in the
hospital 1 to 2 days for observation